bonjour à tous bienvenue sur public
sénat dans moins de quinze minutes les
traditionnelles questions d'actualité
dans l'hémicycle au sénat nous sommes
juste au pied de l'hémicycle est ici
salle des conférences avec nous pour
commencer cette émission 15 minutes
avant les questions d'actualité deux
personnalités très importante la
ministre évidemment avec nos ministres
la réforme de l'état de la
décentralisation et de la fonction
publique marylise lebranchu
merci de répondre à nos questions le
texte est débattu en ce moment au sénat
sur les métropoles la décentralisation
on va y venir bien entendu mais avant
avec notre invité évidemment le
président du sénat jean-pierre bel merci
d'intervenir en direct avec nous on va
parler évidemment de ce qui s'est passé
hier soir à paris clément méric un jeune
étudiant affiliés à l'extrême gauche
dans un syndicat qui a été passé à tabac
littéralement agressé par une bande en
tout cas dit néonazis d'extrême droite
selon le ministre de l'intérieur il est
entre la vie et la mort mort cérébrale
ce que dit aujourd'hui l'hôpital
quel est le témoignage que vous pouvez
nous formuler aujourd'hui est-ce que
selon vous comme le dit manuel valls est
un acte de la marque de l'extrême droite
écoutez d'abord on doit dire que il est
un moment où les choses sont
inacceptables ce qui s'est passé hier
soir n'est pas un acte parmi d'autres ce
qui touche jusqu'à toucher là c'est pas
simplement nos consciences nos
convictions
ce qui est touché là c'est la république
en est de même qu'un jeune étudiant
étudiants en sciences politiques
puissent être de cette manière-là façon
délibérée quasiment prémédité assassiné
à paris pas loin de l'université à
laquelle il appartenait ça appelle pour
nous responsables politiques une
réaction d'ampleur est très solide elles
c'est pourquoi je tiens absolument à le
manifester en ce moment certains disent
que c'est aussi dû au climat qui règne
actuellement dans le climat politique
après les diverses manifestations qui
ont émaillé évidemment la discussion
autour du mariage qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
est-ce que vous pensez que la faute en
revient à ce climat très lourd qui perd
en ce moment en france
vous le savez dans ce pays les des
groupes qui n'accepte pas la démocratie
qui n'acceptent pas de la république qui
n'accepte pas la légitimité démocratique
et à partir de là il génère la violence
et en général dans la violence
ils poursuivent début des objectifs que
nous connaissons bien nous avons connu
toutes les générations
ces groupuscules d'extrême droite
toujours très violent et aujourd'hui
après ce que nous avons vécu vous avez
raison d'en parler
ce climat de violence qu'ils ont eux
même entretenu bien voilà nous arrivons
à ce résultat
un jeune français un jeune étudiant
français assassinés dans les rues de
paris
je crois que nous allons tous
responsables politiques quelles que
soient nos sensibilités à nous exprimer
fortement aujourd'hui et j'appelle tous
ceux qui le pourront a participé aux
manifestations qui sont organisées
alors pour information quand même une
vague d'interpellations selon manuel
valls qui a déclaré l instant qu il ya
une accélération d'une enquête plusieurs
interpellations dont l'auteur présumé
des coups c'est important il faut le
signaler
est ce qu'on peut imaginer dissoudre ces
groupes néo nazis en tout cas proche de
l'extrême droite qui pressent prêchent
la violence
écoutez je ne serais pas du tout choqué
il ya une logique à s'interroger sur
cette question et la dissolution de ces
groupes avec les actions qu'ils
conduisent est ce que nous venons de
connaître irait à mon sens très
fortement dans ce sens donc il faut
faire très attention car il ya des
conditions à remplir pour cela mais moi
je ne vois que des avantages à ce qu'on
puisse stopper de cette manière là mais
ça ne sera pas suffisant
les agissements de ces personnes merci
beaucoup jean pierre bel dans ces cas
évidemment où il y aura un témoignage
juste avant les questions d'actualité
donc dans quelques minutes dans
l'hémicycle vous laisse évidemment
regagné 7 et musique merci d'être
intervenu en direct avec nous marylise
lebranchu faudrait quand même avoir
votre témoignage ancienne garde des
sceaux
faut-il le préciser on parlait à
l'instant de ces groupuscules est ce
qu'on peut imaginer une loi ou un décret
en fonction du degré évidemment d'appel
à la violence pour ces groupuscules
maria déjà dans le code pénal français
des incriminations possible l'incitation
à la haine incitation à la violence le
prosélytisme de la violence du rejet de
la xénophobie etc
mais jean-pierre mais la raison de dire
soyons extrêmement prudent sur ses
déclarations attention ne pas victimiser
certain nombre de personnes qui en
profiteraient peut-être pour entraîner
dans le terrorisme
certains qui se sentiraient
dl en entendant cette exclusion donc je
pense que le président de république le
premier ministre le président du sénat
près dans l'assemblée nationale en
parleront sûrement restons prudents et
très solidaire d'une famille brestoise
qui aujourd'hui est dans une douleur
immense je pense que la république est
blessé nous sommes blessés nous mais
nous sommes solidaires de cette famille
nous leur disons aussi que la république
ne peut pas supporter l'insupportable
que support mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde politique
je dis bien tout le monde politique doit
être interpellée parce que dans une
société fragile en pleine période de
crise les terreaux pour semer la
violence sans parfois plus cher tine
donc toute la société politique tous les
groupes politiques mais aussi les
syndicats les associations doivent se
poser des questions sur cette société
capable de générer de telles violences
c'est à dire justement que les partis
politiques au mal fait ou n'ont pas joué
leur rôle ces dernières semaines au
moment du débat sur le mariage notamment
sur ce débat là pas que moi je ne veux
pas faire le lien entre les deux même si
j'ai été choqués d'un certain nombre de
comportements de mots mais le politique
de et l'ancien garde des sceaux que je
suis envie de vous dire doit toujours
être prudent dans ses conclusions sous
le coup de l'émotion effectivement on a
envie de faire des liens
mais ce restons prudents restant même
aussi peiné que nous soyons restons
sereins mais regardons quand même qu'il
ya un terreau fertile d'une telle
violence qu'on a rencontrés en grande
bretagne qu'on a rencontrés dans
d'autres pays européens qu'on rencontre
à paris ce matin qui interpelle tout le
monde politique d'accord mais je suis
derrière questions sur ce point à quoi
attribuez-vous ce mauvais climat mais je
pense que je ne veux pas rentrer dans un
débat qui deviendrait polémique dans
l'heure qui suit mais lorsqu'on vit une
crise économique violente comme celle
que nous vivons depuis 2008 lorsque
le chômage est très important et lorsque
l'espoir est difficile à vivre à
discerner
alors soyons encore plus prudents et moi
je dis a pas longtemps avant ce drame
terrible faut que les politiques fassent
de la politique à pied qu'ils aillent
rencontrer la population que nous
mêlions expliquer nos politiques allons
expliquer l'espoir que nous avons pour
la france et pour son développement à
nouveau pour éviter que cette espèce
d'ambiance désespéré puisse conduire
certains à rejoindre des mouvements qui
sont pas loin de la barbarie sachez que
manuel valls vient de faire son entrée
ici salle des conférences
on est partis essayé de lui demander
s'ils voulaient également témoigné sur
notre antenne
on verra d'ici peu s'il veut bien
s'exprimer on va parler en attendant de
votre volets le volet décentralisation
lit un texte très important qui est
débattue en ce moment et qui dès sera
sûrement voter visiblement ce soir vous
l'espérez en tout cas il s'agit des
métropoles et pourtant on en entend
parler que ce soit marseille paris il ya
des difficultés et lyon s'est passé
pourquoi comment est-ce que vous
expliquer ses difficultés à faire passer
ce texte qui paraît possède presque
consensuel au premier abord il ya deux
types de difficultés d'abord rappelons
que on a eu des débats très longs sur
les chefs de file sur les conférences de
l'action publique sur la modernité son
action publique et que les choses se
sont bien passées parce que la
commission des lois a bien travaillé
pourquoi c'est difficile parce que vous
ne pouvez pas comparer la région
parisienne avec le haut avec marseille
chacun a sa spécificité
chacun a son histoire et qu'à chaque
fois qu'on avance par la loi il faut que
nous soyons tous attentifs à l'histoire
à la géographie aux habitudes et c'est
vrai que paris par exemple on a vu des
positions extrêmement différents tirs
les uns comme le sait car au-dessus
voulait une métropole région d'autres
voulaient que monsieur dalil métropole
département avec la fusion des
départements
d'autres comme les particuliers français
ne voulait pas du tout
d'intercommunalité dans la première
couronne bref on a vu que l'airé
on n'était pas les mêmes voilà et moi je
pense que si nous avons réussi sur
marseille et je crois à marseille nous
avons toujours eu de grandes difficultés
parce que les mères avaient beaucoup de
craintes et il ya une semaine j'ai eu la
possibilité devant certains maires même
si c'était pas simple vous en rappelez
le sentiment de prendre trois
engagements importants d'une part que
tous les maires seraient représentés au
niveau de la métropole et déjà on avait
fait un pas le deuxième engagement que
j'ai pris devant les maires c'est de
pouvoir leur dire que leur dotation
globale de fonctionnement serre la vis
des finances des communes seraient
totalement préservée et le troisième
engagement que j'ai pris la semaine
dernière c'est que le plan local de
l'urbanisme pourrait être discutée sur
les anciens périmètres des intercoms
donc on avait déjà de l'espoir et je
pense qu'après cette première lecture je
m'engage monsieur povinelli boulari
demandé récemment l'élu marseillais à
ses lecteurs marseillais il me l'a
demandé il a raison je vais revoir entre
la lecture du sénat est la lecture à
l'assemblée nationale
les maires une délégation de maires les
présidents des intercommunalités et moi
je suis et aura quelques rats tout ce
que vous dites
il y aura quelques retouches je pense
qu'un tel qu'il est le texte est de
qualité
nous n'avons pas besoin de retouches
nous avons davantage besoin
d'explication avec les maires qui ont eu
et c'est normal du mal à apprécier et
donc à s'approprier les compétences
transférées c'est compliqué c'est
technique mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui
le brancher deux petites questions très
simples
de quoi ont-ils peur c'est mr est ce que
c'est la fin des départements alors que
le but on va le dire c'est faire des
économies quand même ils ont peur de
quoi de perdre leurs prérogatives c'est
ça je pense qu'il est beaucoup et ça a
été exprimée
sur 10 vers man beaucoup ont peur de
voir disparaître le rôle du maire la
commune la proximité les chiens premier
de la république alors que nous sommes
engagés à le garder d'autres craignent
la disparition des départements
le président de la république lui même
s'est exprimé sauf avis contraire et
volontariat comme à lyon il n'y aura pas
de disparition des départements
donc nous avions beaucoup d'éléments
pour les rassurer
mais les craintes sont restés je pense
que la lecture du projet de loi
le commentaire qu'on pourra en faire les
explications y compris publiques que je
suis prête à faire nous permettront de
montrer surtout que ce sont les
populations qui vont gagner en termes de
transport de logement et le
développement économique et que la
france peut gagner parce que les grandes
métropoles ont toujours générer de la
richesse
merci beaucoup marylise lebranchu je
vous laisse regagné l'hémicycle qui
reliera un moment très important
un hommage en tout cas sont rendus à
clément homérique vous savez à l'instant
jean pierre bel vient de traverser le
couloir depuis le salon du départ il va
s'installer au plateau nous allons
évidemment rejoindre les missiles en
quelques instants
cette information très importante selon
manuel valls venu en tout cas du
ministre de l'intérieur une vague
d'interpellations a eu lieu en fin de
matinée un début d'après midi
l'auteur présumé des coups auraient été
interpellées on parle bien sûr de ce
jeune étudiant de 19 ans de l'école
sciences po de diverses manifestations
ont également lieu dans paris
aujourd'hui l'une à cette école de
sciences po et en fin de journée place à
paris place saint-michel évidemment on
en reparlera sur notre antenne clémot
mairie qui a été victime d'une agression
mortelle hier à paris
boulevard haussmann à paris on va
essayer de rejoindre l'hémicycle dans
quelques instants pour cet hommage des
gens permet l'on écoute
monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues
il est des crimes qui ne frappe pas
seulement les personnes qui ne heurte
pas seulement les consciences il est des
crimes qui meurtrissent notre république
hier soir tellement méric jeunes
étudiants de 20 qui s'ouvraient les
promesses de la vie a été sauvagement
agressé par des éléments d'un
groupuscule qui tient la république en
horreur la représentation nationale
condamne avec la plus grande fermeté cet
acte de haine qui soulève l'indignation
et la colère
ce crime odieux appelle à la plus grande
vigilance et à la mobilisation face au
risque de résurgence d'une idéologie qui
constitue un véritable danger pour la
démocratie
notre république doit être forte
face à des groupes qui la bafouent elle
doit être implacable avec ceux qui
foulent aux pieds nos valeurs
fondamentales de respect de la dignité
humaine de liberté d'expression de
liberté l'expression pardon et de
fraternité il nous appartient de porter
ses idéaux et ses valeurs contre
l'intolérable en votre nom à tous mes
chers collègues
j'adresse mes pensées et ma plus
profonde sympathie à la famille de clés
d'amérique et à ses proches monsieur le
premier ministre je sais que vous aurez
à vous exprimer
dans le cours des questions d'actualité
je vous remercie
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
la parole est à monsieur gérard longuet
pour le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues au
moment de poser ma question au nom du
groupe de l'ump je voudrais apporter au
nom du groupe de l'ump unanime notre
soutien à votre intervention monsieur le
président il était bon que cela soit dit
et vous l'avez dit dans des termes que
nous soutenons
ma question s'adresse à madame marisol
touraine
elles auraient pu s'adresser à monsieur
le premier lit jean marc ayrault parce
que le sujet de la famille est par
nature un sujet interministérielle elle
aurait pu s'adresser plus surprenante à
monsieur valls
tant il est vrai que dans ce
gouvernement en ce qui concerne la
politique de la famille se sont
apparemment les fonctionnaires de son
ministère qui sont chargés d'entretenir
un dialogue inutilement musclé et
excessivement musclé avec ceux qui sont
les partisans de la famille de toujours
mais les réactions la raison de ma
question est haute
elle a trait à la déclaration du
monsieur le président la république
françois hollande qui a décidé
d'augmenter les impôts pour rééquilibrer
le déficit de la caisse nationale
d'allocations familiales
cette décision est surprenante d'abord
parce qu'elle est en contradiction
totale avec ce que le premier le
président de la république avait énoncé
dans sa campagne dans sa conférence de
presse et l'oubli semble-t-il que déjà
la loi de finances 2013 à pénaliser
d'environ 500 millions d'euros
les familles dites les plus aisés au
titre du quotient familial et que cette
mesure nouvelle va donc aboutir pour un
million de foyers adressé une note
supplémentaire d'environ 15 100 euros
par an
ce n'est pas rien qu'est ce qu'un ménage
aisé
c'est simplement un ménage plus anciens
ou l'ancienneté et l'expérience c'est
pourquoi ne pas le dire la réussite
n'est pas un mot grossier abouti en
effet à
payer plus d'impôts quel est l'objectif
du quotient familial
ce n'est pas de rétablir à l'intérieur
des familles l'equilibre c'est de faire
en sorte que les familles qui ont des
enfants ne soient pas pénalisés à
l'égard des familles qui n'ont pas
d'enfant c'est la raison pour laquelle
madame marisol touraine ma question est
la suivante
au moment où s'ouvre le débat sur les
retraites
allez vous remettre en chantier une
mesure de bon sens qui est de faire
prendre en charge le supplément pour les
mères de famille qui ont élevé trois
enfants et plus à la caisse nationale
d'assurance vieillesse et non pas à
concurrence de 4 milliards 100 millions
par la seule cnav
si vous faisiez cet effort nous
pourrions épargné les familles qui ont
pris la responsabilité d'avoir des
enfants lors épargné une taxe
supplémentaire alors que ce sont
justement ces enfants qui par leur
présence à sur l' équilibre du régime
vieillesse dans nos moeurs et ima
répartition merci la parole à madame
dominique bertinotti ministre chargée de
la famille monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur si j'entends bien
votre question il est urgent surtout de
ne rien faire
il est urgent il est urgent de ne rien
faire
et alors que nous avons hérité d'une
branche famille avec un déficit de plus
de 2,6 milliards
un déficit que vous avez vous même
creusé donc il en va il en va
effectivement de la volonté de pouvoir
pérenniser consolidé défendre de notre
modèle social dont la politique
familiale est un des éléments importants
et ne pas vouloir réduire les déficits
delà de la branche famille c'est
effectivement lourdement hypothéqué
l'avenir même de la qualité de la
politique familiale la deuxième défi
auquel nous sommes confrontés c'est de
lutter contre la pauvreté des familles
il faut vous rappeler là aussi qu'un
enfant sur cinq est considéré comme
pauvre l'unicef
à pointer avec une réalité qui n'est pas
à notre honneur que nous sommes très mal
placée en dépit des prestations
financières que nous pouvons à louer au
fait que nous avons une situation de nos
enfants pauvres tout à fait contestable
enfin si vous regardez ce que sont les
attentes de nos concitoyens et de nos
concitoyennes
c'est la volonté de développer des
services d aide à la famille et en
particulier d'avoir une politique
volontariste en la matière pour
développer les places d'accueil des 0 3
ans et contrairement à vous ne pas
diminuer par exemple de 55000 les places
de près scolarisation des enfants dès 2
3 ans alors face à cela je voudrais
aussi pointé dans justement sur les
bancs de la droite que vous n'êtes pas
unanime
car moi je me souviens des propos
d'alain juppé de xavier bertrand
voire même de raymond soubie qui dit que
lorsqu'on est en période de crise il
faut justement défendre notre système de
protection sociale en s'adressant et en
allant là vers les plus démunis pour
justement remettre en cause la question
de la pérennité des allocations
familiales sur les couches les plus
aisées
le choix qui a été fait par le
gouvernement est la solution la plus
juste la plus efficace qui est
effectivement de d'abaisser le seuil du
plafond du quotient familial qui
concerne moins de 12 % des familles cela
signifie que 88 % des familles n'est pas
concerné et effectivement c'est une
politique juste et efficace pour la
pérennité de notre politique familiale
merci la parole à madame chantal jouanno
pour le groupe lui d y eut ce monsieur
le président l'ensemble du groupe
udi s'associer au message extrêmement
juste que vous avez prononcé
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
très certainement lu un rapport très
intéressant le baromètre de
l'attractivité publiée par ernst and
young qui signale que
l'implantation d'entreprises étrangères
en france s'est effondré en 2012 -13%
que c'est une situation inédite depuis
plus de dix ans alors même qu'en europe
par exemple chez nos voisins allemands
ou anglais
l'implantation d'entreprises étrangères
a triplé l'année dernière et là je ne
vous parle pas de finances je vous parle
d'emploi un emploi salarié sur huit dans
ses filiales je vous parle de recherche
un quart de la recherche un tiers des
exportations
le message que nous envoie ses
investisseurs est simple quand vous
déciderez vous a changé d'orientation
politique comme d'autres pays l'ont fait
d'ailleurs un message que jean louis
borloo raisonnement en détresse termes
très simples
vous avez une politique qui conduit à un
massacre économique et social dois je
vous rappeler que vous avez avec le cic
eu à peine compensé les 30 milliards de
prélèvements obligatoires
supplémentaires voter ce que nous dit
cet investisseur
arrêtez arrêtez de dégrader notre
compétitivité
dois je vous rappeler qu'en septembre
vous aviez promis la stabilité fiscale
et les investisseurs ont besoin de
stabilité fiscale
dois je vous rappeler qu'au sein de
votre propre gouvernement vous n'avez
jamais démenti les pourfendeurs de ces
entrepreneurs alors aurez vous le
courage de donner un message très clair
ou de l'un des discours mais plutôt dans
les actes un message très clair la
priorité aujourd'hui est d'aider les
entreprises
alors nos questions sont très simples
aurez vous le courage de remplacer le
séisme par une véritable tva sociale de
50 à 60 milliards d'euros
aurez vous le courage de dire en france
que vous avez imposées aux
fonctionnaires européens à savoir
travailler deux heures trente de plus
par semaine
aurez vous le courage aussi de condamner
les propos de vos ministres quand il
désavoue les entrepreneurs c'est une
priorité absolue
on ne vous le demande pas pour renoncer
à vouziers au logis on vous demande
juste pour la france
si la parole est un monsieur jean marc
ayrault premier ministre monsieur le
président merci madame la ministre
chantal jouanno
vous avez lu attentivement un rapport
d'un cabinet d'expertisé ernst & young
et qui comme vous l'avez certainement
remarqué s'arrête à l'année 2012 et donc
comme vous avez été membre du
gouvernement précédent
vous n'avez sans doute pas perdu la
mémoire et que vous devez sans doute
pensé que cette évaluation porte sur les
dix dernières années c'est à dire la
période où la droite les conservateurs
en gouverner la france
le président de la république a été élu
le 6 mai 2012 et moi même j'ai été nommé
le 15 mai 2012 avec un programme une
feuille de route qui est celle de
redresser la france de lui permettre de
retrouver des marges de manoeuvre en
maîtrisant ses déficits publics de
redonner à notre économie toute sa force
et sa compétitivité
mais en même temps de réformer notre
système social
que ce soit la branche famille la
politique de santé ou encore notre
système de retraites non pas pour le
détruire
mais pour le sauver c'est tout la tâche
du gouvernement
c'est à quoi nous consacrons tous les
efforts depuis le premier jour est donc
ici et maintenant avec l'objectif en
effet que notre pays retrouve toute son
attractivité
parce qu'il a perdu en effet une partie
de ces tracteurs d'attractivité mais
j'aimerais que vous ayez avec nous un
discours un peu plus positif est un peu
plus généreux à l'égard de la france
nous restons la cinquième puissance
économique du monde
nous avons un niveau de qualité de vie
et d'infrastructures inégalée mais nous
avons des réformes à faire la réforme de
notre système éducatif où c'est vrai que
l'école de la république ne respectent
pas toutes ses promesses de former notre
jeunesse et c'est le chantier de la
refondation de l'école vous en avait
parlé il ya quelques jours c'est aussi
la réforme des collectivités
territoriales pour qu'elle soit plus
efficace
et le sénat y apporte sa contribution et
je m'en félicite
mais ce sont tous les autres chantiers
dont un en effet où l'avait mentionné
vous avez parlé du crédit d'impôt
compétitivité emploi
vous auriez pu parler par exemple de la
réforme du marché du travail
sécurisation des parcours professionnels
d'un côté et plus grande flexibilité de
l'autre et le sénat s'est prononcé c'est
maintenant devenu la loi de la
république
le chantier de la formation
professionnelle il est devant nous pour
plus d'efficacité c'est tout ça que nous
avons entrepris pour redonner à la
france toute sa force pour lui permettre
de retrouver son rôle leader en europe
elle le peut les français en ont la
capacité
il ya beaucoup de choses qui marchent
heureusement dans notre pays mais nous
voulons que la france soit plus fort
plus attractif mais elle le sera que si
elle est plus juste et j'aimerais bien
que vous vous soyez justes et lucide
avec ce que vous avez été incapable de
faire avec ce qui a contribué à
affaiblir la france
et bien soyez lucides et retrouver en
quelque sorte un peu de lucidité pour
soutenir l'entreprise de redressement
que nous avons engagées
merci nous en revenons maintenant à deux
questions qui portent sur le même sujet
et avec l'autorisation de leurs auteurs
le premier ministre répondra ou deux
ensemble la parole est à madame laurence
rossignol pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le premier ministre hier soir
clément méric jeune brestois étudiant à
l'iut de paris a été battu à mort par un
groupe de skinheads ce matin une famille
des parents des amis le pleurent nous
partageons leur émotion et leur
tristesse
je pense mes chers collègues qu'il y a
des moments où le silence c'est le
respect jeudi ce matin leurs familles
leurs parents leurs amis le pleurent
nous partageons leur émotion et leur
tristesse
ce matin ce sont la république et sa
jeunesse qui sont meurtris
depuis quelques temps des individus
solitaires ou en meute parade affichant
les mêmes codes vestimentaires et
physique à savoir ceux des groupuscules
d'extrême droite néo nazis identitaire
ils affichent leurs idées il les diffuse
la banalisation de leur discours de
leurs idées de leur présence ont conduit
à des passages à l'acte il y a peu de
temps
le président du groupe front national au
conseil régional rhône alpes après des
agressions commises à lyon nous accusait
de jouer à faire peur le dramatique
événement qui s'est produit hier soir
témoigne que non ce n'est pas un jeu et
que oui nous avions des bonnes raisons
d'avoir peur ces individus sont
particulièrement actifs sur les réseaux
sociaux où il dévoile avec arrogance
leurs idées anti républicaine
antisémistes racistes homophobes et
misogynes protégé par la toile
ils pensent pouvoir s'exprimer en toute
impunité monsieur le premier ministre
on est pourriez vous nous indiquer si
vous avez déjà des éléments des enquêtes
à nous communiquer
quels moyens vous entendez développé
pour repérer en amont ces individus sur
le net et dans quelles conditions ces
groupes pourraient être dissous et mis
hors la loi
merci la parole est pas madame se situe
kerman pour le groupe communiste
républicain et citoyen
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mes chers collègues la
violence fasciste la violence d'extrême
droite et c'est bien d'elle dont il
s'agit a frappé dans les rues de paris
hier soir un jeune homme de 19 ans
clément méric serait aujourd'hui en état
de mort cérébrale après l'agression
sauvage dont il a été victime sa famille
ses amis ses camarades sont aujourd'hui
dans la souffrance et se prépare à un
deuil que rien ne pouvait prévoir pour
clément étudiant à sciences po auquel la
vie ouvrez les bras nous partageons sur
les bancs du groupe communiste
républicain et citoyen cette souffrance
et nous sommes persuadés que l'ensemble
des démocrates et républicains nous
rejoignent aujourd'hui dans ce sentiment
nous serons ce soir à 18h30 place saint
michel aux côtés de tous ceux qui
peinait choqué révolté vient de faire
savoir que la france ne veut pas de
cette haine primaire qu'il refuse la
multiplication des actes violents et
xénophobes racistes homophobes qui se
développe depuis plusieurs mois nous
avons demandé la suspension des travaux
du sénat durant la manifestation
ensemble ce soir nous diront ça suffit
cette violence n'est pas le fruit du
hasard
depuis des années l'agressivité se
développe dans notre société la crise
profonde
la montée effroyable du chômage de la
précarité des heures sombres de
l'histoire du monde la teste suscite des
comportements de repli sur soi et de
recherche des boucs émissaires
le racisme et la xénophobie la mise en
cause de la démocratie se développe
quand la société va mal malheureusement
le mal se répand parfois si vite que le
temps peut manquer pour réagir le crime
commis hier soir par des individus qui
de toute évidence appartiennent à la
mouvance de l'extrême droite doit être
un avertissement suprême
la république doit réagir elle doit
empêcher de nuire ceux qui sapent
l'idéal de fraternité et de solidarité
qu'elle porte en son sein
il faut monsieur le premier ministre
prendre les mesures de dissolution de
certains groupes
schiste nous ne pouvons plus attendre la
république se doit de combattre les
idées de haine véhiculés par l'extrême
droite
chaque atteinte à l'idéal républicain
doit être prise et combattu fermement
pied à pied
monsieur le premier ministre nous
comptons sur votre gouvernement pour que
les auteurs présumés de l'agression
mortelle soient jugés et sanctionnés
nous comptons sur les décisions fortes
et vous pouvez compter sur nous pour
renforcer plus que jamais notre
vigilance républicaine et ne plus
tolérer un seul discours d'extrême
droite qui aujourd'hui a tué un tel
crime ne doit pas se reproduire
la république doit aujourd'hui se
dresser pour ensemble dire stop
allen merci la parole est un monsieur
jean marc ayrault premier ministre merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
président du sénat vous avez trouvé les
mots il ya quelques instants en ouvrant
cette séance vous l'avez fait de façon
solennelle et je voudrais vous en
remercier parce que dans ces moments en
effet comme vous l'avez dit mesdames les
sénatrices madame rossignol man a pu
kerman avec vos mots qui était quasiment
les mêmes qu'il est important que la
représentation nationale s'exprime de
façon solennelle et sachent se
rassembler sur l'essentiel c'est-à-dire
de défendre sans faiblesse sans
hésitation sans aucun doute les valeurs
républicaines
ce qui s'est passé hier soir dont nous
avons eu connaissance tardivement mais
dont les radios les télévisions par les
taux ce matin c'est à dire la mort d'un
jeune homme clément méric victime d'une
agression victime d'un gris crime odieux
hier a profondément troublé les français
les a indignés pas seulement nous les
membres ou les membres de la
représentation nationale où les membres
du gouvernement mais les français dans
leur immense majorité
ne se reconnaissent pas ni dans la haine
ni dans la violence qui la refusent et
qu'ils veulent qu'on la combattre avec
la plus grande fermeté
je tiens à le dire ici devant l'om
mesdames et messieurs vous laisse les
sénateurs c'est la volonté du
gouvernement c'est l'engagement du
gouvernement
il est totale et il sera sans faiblesse
j'ai été informé juste avant cette
séance par le ministre de l'intérieur
manuel valls que les auteurs présumés de
ce crime avait été arrêté ils sont
plusieurs
je fais toute confiance 1 direction
régionale de la police judiciaire sous
l'autorité du parquet pour mener au bout
cette enquête
je ne doute pas que la justice fera
preuve de la plus grande sévérité
tout simplement en application des lois
qui sont celles de la république
mais c'est vrai que en cet instant comme
vous je pense aux parents de clément
méric qui ont déjà dans leur histoire
familiale connu d'autres drames qui
aujourd'hui sont profondément touché par
ce qui leur arrive
et donc je voudrais leur exprimer notre
solidarité notre affection la plus
totale je voudrais dire aussi notre
soutien à tous ces jeunes ces jeunes
étudiants qui font leurs études qui
aussi savent défendre des idées mais qui
les défendent avec les mots avec la
vigueur qui convient mais en refusant la
violence et en refusant la haine et
d'autres responsabilités aujourd'hui
c'est non seulement de veiller à ce que
ses idées ne prospère pas qu'elles ne
trouvent pas leur place mais c'est aussi
de trouver les réponses juridiques
politiques pour que tous ces mouvements
racistes antisémites et xénophobes
homophobes qui sont contraires à toutes
les valeurs de la république soient
combattues y compris par les moyens de
droit telles que vous avez évoquées j'ai
demandé au ministre de l'intérieur
j'ai demandé à la garde des sceaux
d'étudier toutes les possibilités qui
permettront de
tailler en pièces en quelque sorte de
façon démocratique
sur la base du droit ces mouvements
d'inspiration fasciste et néo nazis et
qui font tort à la république et qui
font tort à la france ils sont ultra
minoritaires mais parfois ils veulent
tenir le haut du pavé avec des armes des
coups de poing américains ou d'autres
moyens
mais c'est d'abord la haine qui les
inspirent avec des idéologies qui ont
fait tant de mal à la france qui ont
fait tant de mal à l'europe
elles n'ont pas complètement disparu
nous le savons donc en tout instant en
tout moment nous devons les combattre et
le gouvernement les combattra et je suis
sûr que à chaque fois que cela sera
nécessaire
le parlement soutiendra merci d'y
veiller
nous y veillerons ensemble
je remercie monsieur le premier ministre
de votre intervention
je passe la parole à notre collègue
esther benbassa pour le groupe
écologiste
je m'associe au nom du groupe écologiste
aux paroles d'indignation et de
solidarité exprimée par monsieur le
président du sénat monsieur le premier
ministre et mes collègues sénatrice
monsieur le président chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre des affaires européennes
monsieur le ministre
depuis quelques années le gouvernement
islamo-conservateur au pouvoir en
turquie s'oriente vers l'instauration de
régimes autoritaires au nom de l'islam
rigoriste dont il se revendique dans un
pays à la solide tradition laïque
il impose chaque jour de nouvelles
restrictions aux libertés individuelles
des intellectuels et des journalistes
sont emprisonnés pour délit d'opinion
à quoi s'ajoutent les discriminations
contre les lgbt les minorités et
l'érosion des droits des femmes
la sensuelle enfin est devenu une
pratique courante
le combat des habitants d'istanbul pour
la sauvegarde de leur ville commence il
ya sept jours s'est vite transformé en
révolte contre le régime liberticide de
tayyip erdogan
les violences policières ont fait
plusieurs morts et de très nombreux
blessés
malgré les excuses présentées à la
nation par le vice premier ministre turc
la tension ne faiblit pas et le
mouvement s'amplifie nous le groupe
écologiste du sénat nous vous demandons
monsieur le ministre d'intervenir comme
angela merkel et john kerry auprès du
gouvernement turc pour que cessent les
violences policières et pour l'inciter à
respecter les valeurs et les principes
chers à l'union européenne incluant les
libertés de manifestation et de réunion
l'expression et d'opinion pour que la
turquie hfc réforme et se démocratise
pleinement
encore aurait-il fallu une pas fermé
devant elle
les ports de l'union européenne déçu par
ce refus elle s'est spontanément tourner
vers l'est musulmans lieux mythiques de
ses origines
c'est dans une tentation qui hante le
l'histoire du pays
ainsi en fut-il au 19e siècle avec le
panislamisme et plus tard avec
l'automatisme des jeunes-turcs
actuellement un tiers seulement des tur
souhaite entrer dans l'union européenne
nous européens avons laissé le régime
des douanes s'installer durablement dans
le pays
c'est génial détruire les traces du
kémalisme laïque dont la place de taksim
est un des symboles et haï rogner des
libertés des droits fondamentaux dont il
n'a que faire les démocrates turcs
résiste l'europe a le devoir d'amener au
plus vite la turquie une fois devenus
démocratiques à rejoindre l'union
quelle est donc la position de la france
à ce sujet aujourd'hui monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur thierry rolland terre
ministre chargé des affaires européennes
le président madame la sénatrice vous
avez fait référence à un mouvement
effectivement des stambouliotes contre
la politique conservatrice du
gouvernement turc je veux dire que face
à al usage excessif des forces de
l'ordre à l'égard de la jeunesse qui a
manifesté la france a appelé et appelle
à la retenue effectivement vis-à-vis des
manifestations démocratiques qui se sont
exprimés la répression policière a fait
deux morts deux mille blessés
1700 à l'arrestation temporaire
c'est trop aucune démocratie ne peut se
construire effectivement sur la
répression de celles et ceux qui
s'expriment dans la rue nous le disons
le droit de manifester
le droit de s'opposer doit être respecté
aucune démocratie ne peut se construire
sur des bases qui ne respecteraient pas
ce principe
vous avez ensuite fait référence au fait
que la turquie est un partenaire
important souhaite effectivement
s'arrimer à l'europe
eh bien la france et l'union européenne
travaillent dans cette perspective de
développement d'une relation stable et
de confiance avec la turquie
elle veut accompagner la turquie vers la
démocratie
la relation à capture qui permet du coup
aussi de traiter des sujets tels que
ceux que vous avez abordé devant
l'hémicycle
c'est pour cela que la france a choisi
en mai dernier effectivement de tourner
avec la position initiale de l'ancien
gouvernement et qu'en février de cette
année nous avons des notre ouverture
pour que les négociations reprennent
notamment sur le chapitre 22 de la
politique régionale préalable à toute
négociation pour à arrimer la turquie
définitivement à l'union européenne
nous avons fait donc un geste à l'égard
de la turquie
mais ce geste ne doit pas être à sens
unique
il faut que les autorités turques fasse
preuve aussi d'avancer à l'égard du
respect de la démocratie des droits de
l'homme mais aussi pour qu'elle avance
vers des réformes et l'alignement sur
l'acquis communautaire qu'elle prenne en
compte la question chypriote pour nous
c'est une question essentielle et
qu'elle soit aussi en coopération sur
les questions migratoires
c'est pour cela madame la sénatrice que
je verrai la semaine prochaine mon
collègue turc chargé des affaires
européennes monsieur binche et je le
rencontrerai dans cet esprit à la fois
d'ouverture mais aussi des exigences qui
je pense peut réunir l'ensemble des
parlementaires dans cet hémicycle
merci la parole à monsieur pierre yves
collombat pour le groupe rdse
c'est le président monsieur le ministre
chers collègues on ne tombe pas amoureux
d'une courbe de croissance proclamait la
jeunesse révoltée en 1968
encore moins d'une courbe de chômage
pourrait répondre ses petits enfants
étonnamment sage d'aujourd'hui non
seulement cette courbe monte
mois après mois mais accélère dans la
montée d'avril 2012 à avril 2013 selon
la dares plus 361 1700 chômeurs de
catégorie a soit une moyenne d'un peu
plus de 30000 par mois entre mars et
avril 2013 la progression pro tangente
quarante mille demandeurs d'emploi si
rien ne change
calculer ce que cela donnera dans un an
3264289 d'emploi de catégories hier en
avril 2013
nous n'avions jamais connu une situation
aussi préoccupante bien évidemment le
chômage de longue durée progresse lui
aussi bien évidemment les plus touchés
sont les moins de 25 ans et les plus de
50 ans ce qui laisse rêveur sur toute
réforme des retraites qui allongerait la
durée des cotisations sans diminuer le
chômage
de ceux qui sont censés cotisé sachant
aussi que moins de 50% des demandeurs
d'emploi sont indemnisés
pas étonnant donc que la consommation
des ménages et leur pouvoir d'achat est
aussi baisser en 2012
malgré tout j'ai cru comprendre que le
gouvernement reste optimiste annonçant
même une inversion de la tendance pour
la fin de 2013
ce que pas mal de conjoncturistes récuse
personnellement je ne demande qu'à être
convaincu
j'aimerais donc monsieur le ministre
vous m'expliquer comment une
consommation nationale en baisse comment
la poursuite de la même politique de
l'offre mais ma sortie du volet social
des emplois d'avenir qu'il faut soutenir
pourrait donner des résultats différents
de ceux qui a donné jusque là sauf à
admettre comme l'allemagne que la guerre
économique en europe est la solution du
problème
merci la parole est à monsieur michel
sapin ministre du travail de l'emploi de
la formation professionnelle et du
dialogue social
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur vous avez décrit à juste titre
la situation du chômage parce que cette
situation du chômage pour le dire en
sens inverse de l'emploi dégradée est la
préoccupation principale des français de
ceux qui sont au chômage
mais de ceux qui pourraient craindre de
lettres ou de craindre au tour de l'un
d'eux dans leur famille dans leur
entreprise que ce chômage s'installe
vous avez décrit depuis avril dernier ce
sont les chiffres il son objectif mais
la gravité de la situation vient du fait
que ce n'est pas une augmentation depuis
un an c'est une augmentation depuis cinq
ans cinq ans où chaque mois le ministre
du travail quel qu'il soit aujourd'hui
moi même hier d'autres annoncent une
augmentation du nombre des chômeurs je
peux vous rappeler cette période où ça
n'était pas trente mille chômeurs de
plus ce n'était pas quarante mille
chômeurs de plus
c'était 70000 80 mille chômeurs de plus
par mois et c'est ça la gravité de la
situation et c'est à cette situation
cumulées depuis des années et des années
qu'il faut aujourd'hui répond comment me
demandez-vous d'abord et je n'assisterai
pas sur cet aspect qui est très
important par le soutien à l'activité
économique le crédit impôt pour la cause
pour la compétitivité et l'emploi qui
permet aux entreprises de disposer d'un
certain nombre de milliards nécessaires
à l'investissement et au soutien à
l'emploi le contrat de génération qui
permet là aussi aux employeurs qui
hésiteraient à embaucher d'embaucher un
jeune sans pour autant et vous souligner
cet aspect là très important des choses
mettre un plus âgé d'or car à quoi
sert-il de mettre un plus âgé d'or alors
qu'il lui faut attendre pendant de plus
longues robes aux années le droit de
partir à la retraite
et puis c'est tout les politiques de
l'emploi celles que vous avez soutenu
dans cet hémicycle largement souvent les
emplois d'avenir ou bien les emplois et
des classiques que vous avez su utiliser
aussi en son temps et que nous voudrons
utile nous voulons utiliser de manière
plus pertinente encore les emplois
d'avenir
c'est en train de décoller et de marché
ayez cela en tête et vous même la qui
poussé un cri qui me paraît mal venu par
rapport à la situation des jeunes
auxquels on veut répondre
mobilisez-vous aussi dans vos
départements et ça sera quand même
meilleur pour la france et pour les
français que de pousser des cris ainsi
parfaitement insipide dans cet hémicycle
se sont aussi l'ensemble des emplois
aidés nous avons le pré le premier
ministre a décidé l'allongement de la
durée des emplois d'aidé à 12 mois
parce que hier au phalère ernière la
moyenne des emplois aidés et aides six
mois cumulés pendant un seul semestre
le premier semestre de l'année 2012
allez donc savoir pourquoi
et bien maintenant c'est 12 mois pour
permettre une bonne insertion des
chômeurs en particulier de longue durée
voilà monsieur le sénateur les
politiques qui sont en place les
politiques qui se monte en puissance
les politiques qui vont nous permettre
avec une croissance retrouvée d'inverser
effectivement une courbe du chômage dont
personne n'est capable de tomber à merci
merci
la parole est à madame elisabeth lamure
le groupe younès merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question et pour madame pinel madame la
ministre à nouveau feuilleton sème la
perplexité
car il se déroule sur fond de cacophonie
vous travaillez sur la réforme du
dispositif de l'auto-entrepreneur il ya
quelques jours le gouvernement a fait un
certain nombre de révélations à ce sujet
par la voix de plusieurs ministres mais
des voix pour le moins discordante
vous annonciez vous même le 23 mai des
mesures destinées à restreindre la durée
et l'activité des auto entrepreneurs
c'est alors que des centaines de
milliers de poussins se sont fait
entendre
le premier ministre a immédiatement
déclaré vendredi dernier que les mesures
se limiterait aux secteurs du bâtiment
et que pour les autres il n'y avait pas
d'inquiétude à avoir
dans le même sens le ministre du budget
a indiqué que bercy ne procéderait qu'à
des changements à la marge
ensuite vous même madame la ministre
vous avez en quelque sorte tenter de
rétablir la vérité en déclarant que jean
marc ayrault avait cité le bâtiment
comme exemple qu'on avait mal interprété
ses propos mais que la réforme ne se
limiterait pas au seul secteur du
bâtiment
et dire que récemment laurent fabius se
félicitait d'entendre moins deux couacs
au gouvernement au final dans ce dossier
quelles sont les intentions du
gouvernement
vous avez beaucoup décrié ce régime
pourtant vous ne semblez pas vouloir le
supprimer
nous l'avions nous même modifié et
amélioré après avoir écouté les
professionnels vous ferez sans doute vos
propres propositions pour rapprocher les
auto entrepreneurs des régimes de
l'artisanat mais vous qui êtes justement
ministre de l'artisanat
la meilleure manière d'aider les
artisans c'est de baisser leurs charges
c'est de simplifier leurs démarches sus
tt de ne pas augmenter leurs cotisations
pas plus que d'augmenter la tva au 1er
janvier prochain la seraient les bonnes
mesures pour favoriser l'entrepreneuriat
que nous soutenons souffler en
permanence le chaud et le froid annoncé
tout et on est son contraire est de
nature à inquiéter alors au milieu de ce
brouhaha de déclarations contradictoires
à
orthez nous une clarification nous en
avons tous besoin et les entrepreneurs
plus que les autres merci la parole à
sylvia pinel ministre de l'artisanat du
commerce et du tourisme
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice et elisabeth lamure vous
m'interrogez sur la réforme du régime de
l'auto-entrepreneur que le gouvernement
souhaite conduire
je regrette le ton polémique que vous
avez employé caricatural vous
m'interrogez sur un sujet important qui
concerne de nombreux français qui
constitue l'essentiel de nos tpe et qui
mérite de clarifier et de reformuler un
certain nombre de propos que vous
déformez vous êtes vous même dans une
famille politique qui ici ou là peut
demander une évolution législative du
régime de l'auto entrepreneur c'est le
cas de certains députés ump à
l'assemblée nationale
c'est aussi le cas de certains députés
de l'ump lors de la commission des
affaires économiques qui expliquent
qu'il y a en effet certains écueils à ce
régime
donc parlez moi de la cohérence vous qui
semblez aujourd'hui dire qu aucune
réforme n'est nécessaire alors je vais
vous présenter madame la sénatrice et
les trois objectifs que vise le
gouvernement dans cette réforme
d'abord c'est de préserver préserver ce
régime qui a permis de libérer l'esprit
d'entreprendre qui a permis par sa
simplicité de faciliter la création
d'entreprise le deuxième objectif c'est
de l'améliorer de le rendre plus claire
plus efficace pour permettre de
développer de véritables projets
d'entreprises d'entreprendre et de ne
pas voir cela comme un statut précaire
ce que vous n'avez pas voulu faire
puisque vous n'avez pas souhaité
accompagner ces auto entrepreneurs pour
passer à la vitesse supérieure nous
nous le proposons nous voulons enfin
corriger certaines lacunes certaines
erreurs des témoignages de plus en plus
nombreux me parviennent sur le
contournement du droit du travail en
matière de salariat déguisé
c'est aussi un des objectifs de cette
réforme c'est la raison pour laquelle je
poursuis sept compères de cause cette
concertation au nom du gouvernement j'ai
reçu ce matin les organisations
professionnelles de l'artisanat qui ont
fait des propositions
je reçois tout à l'heure les fédération
des auto-entrepreneurs parce que
l'objectif du gouvernement c'est de
réconcilier tous les entrepreneurs de
france pour la réussite économique de
notre pays
merci la parole à madame marie noelle
linemann pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le ministre délégué auprès de
madame la ministre chargée de l'égalité
des territoires et du logement
je voudrais vous interroger sur les
décisions récentes prises par le
gouvernement en matière de logement
comme vous le savez monsieur le premier
ministre et le gouvernement ont dès
votre arrivée pris des mesures
essentielles pour enrayer la crise du
logement et la crise la construction
d'ailleurs c'était bienvenu car on avait
déjà des prévisions de chute de
construction extrêmement alarmantes ces
mesures je le rappelle très rapidement
mais il faut le souligner parce que leur
efficacité en train de se mettre sur le
terrain
premièrement mise à disposition des
terrains publics de l'état gratuitement
pour faire du logement social régulation
des loyers à la relocation durcissement
de la loi sru pour réussir la mixité
sociale en même temps augmentation des
aides à la pierre alors qu'elle baissé
jusqu alors et enfin suppression de l'
indigne prélèvement sur les organismes
hlm
c'était déjà une action substantielle
mais le président de la république le 21
mars
parce qu'il sait que la politique du
logement est une politique lente à voir
ses effets sur le terrain et parce
qu'ils y attachent une importance
capitale a décidé de lancer un plan
d'urgence dans ce plan d'urgence ya deux
volets le volet simplification avec les
lois d'habilitation
nous sommes en train de discuter
mégapoles et 106
et quitte à voler une décision positive
remettre le logement social comme un
bien de première nécessité en octroyant
une tva à 5 pour le logement social car
si nous avons des reculs de construction
c'est que le gouvernement précédent
avait fait passer cette tva à 7
il y a donc eu un progrès avec ses
décisions et ça ça me rendait difficile
le bouclage de certaines opérations
alors maintenant que cette décision est
prise il faut la faire entrer dans les
réalités et il est important pour les
acteurs du logement monsieur le ministre
de bien connaître le champ de cette tva
le logement locatif social
l'accession sociale à la propriété avec
deux sujets premièrement ce qu'on
appelle la location-accession le ps est
là et la construction en zones aux rues
de renouvellement urbain sujets que vous
connaissez parfaitement puis enfin la
tva 5 pour la rénovation de ce parc
social
ce qui est tout à fait essentiel à la
fois pour les charges mais pour la
qualité de vie dans nos quartiers
alors je vous interroge monsieur le
ministre j'ai entendu la ministre
faire un certain nombre d' annonce mais
je crois que l'ensemble des acteurs
souhaitent maintenant y voir clair
quel est le champ d'application des tv à
c'est une très bonne décision je ne
doute pas que si la clarification est
fait et la mobilisation des acteurs du
logement social réussi nous pourrons
semble tenir les engagements du
président de la république deux cent
cinquante mille logements sociaux par an
merci monsieur françois lamy ministre
chargé de la ville et merci un merci
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice marie noëlle lienemann je vous
demande d'abord d'excusés ce cil du faux
qui représente aujourd'hui le
gouvernement au colloque sur des
nouvelles ruralités à vichy je crois
qu'elle sait votre engagement en faveur
du logement et la respecte et pouvoir
répondre à ma place pour vous rappeler
l'engagement est l'ambition du
gouvernement en faveur de la
construction et du logement
vous avez un précisé rappeler les
premières mesures qui avaient été prises
par par cécile duflot et par le premier
ministre pourra permettra d'arriver à
cet objectif de 150 mille logements
sociaux par an et pour préserver les
emplois dans le secteur du bâtiment
vous avez rappelé
les mesures prises par le président de
la république et tout particulièrement
le plan d'investissement pôle logement
quiconque il comprend une mesure très
attendue par les acteurs du secteur la
baisse de la tva à 5% dans le domaine de
la construction et de la réhabilitation
de logements sociaux
je tiens à vous préciser que c'est tva à
taux réduit pourra également s'appliquer
à la location accession
vous aurez l'occasion d'en débattre lors
de l'examen de la prochaine loi de
finances en outre afin de lever les
freins à la construction une série de
huit mesures consensuelles largement
concertée a dans le cadre de la
préparation de la loi logement et
urbanisme que cécile duflot présentera à
la rentrée en septembre pour être prise
par voie d'ordonnancé je les rappelle
une procédure intégré pour le logement
qui fusionnent et délègue au lieu de les
empiler un géoportail de l'urbanisme
l'augmentation du taux maximal de
garantie d'emprunt pour les
collectivités territoriales des mesures
en faveur de la densification la lutte
contre les recours abusifs la création
d'un statut du logement intermédiaire la
suppression de la possibilité de
garantie intrinsèque pour les opérations
de ventes de logements en l'état futur
d'achèvement et enfin la facilitation de
la gestion de la trésorerie des
entreprises du bâtiment
ce projet de loi qui sera adopté avant
la fin du mois de juin habilitera donc
le gouvernement à prendre des
ordonnances dans les délais variant de 4
à 8 mois
ainsi des dispositions relatives au
contentieux d'urbanisme concertée dans
le cadre d'un groupe de travail pour
être adopté en conseil des ministres dès
le mois de juillet ces dispositions
permettent la création de la procédure
intégré pour le logement et des
dérogations en faveur de densification
doivent faire l'objet d'ajustements
précis avec les partenaires enfin vous
avez parlé de plan d'investissement pour
le logement il repose sur la
mobilisation massive des acteurs du
secteur nous signerons donc avant l'été
avec le monde hlm impact symbole de
notre ambition commune qui matérialisera
nos efforts et notre engagement mutuel
en inscrivant de façon cohérente et
pragmatique nos objectifs
vous le voyez le gouvernement dispose de
l'énergie de la volonté et de l'ambition
nécessaire pour parvenir dès 2014 à la
construction de leurs sims munitions
merci la parole à monsieur jacky le menn
pour le groupe socialiste merci monsieur
le président ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre déléguée à la famille
madame la ministre avec courage et
détermination du gouvernement pour ce
avec courage et détermination le
gouvernement poursuit depuis un an une
politique de redressement de notre pays
en annonçant lundi qu'il privilégiait la
réduction du quotient familial à une
baisse des allocations familiales
le premier ministre a confirmé l'option
prise à l'automne dernier dans le cadre
des projets de loi de finances et de
financement de la sécurité sociale
assure et l'universalité des prestations
sociales tout en renforçant la
progressivité de l'impôt sur le revenu
nous sommes en effet face à un défi
important continuer à adapter notre
politique familiale aux évolutions de la
société et aux besoins croissants qui en
découlent notamment en terme d'accueil
des enfants dans un contexte financier
difficile
plutôt que de contribuer à la réflexion
commune sur le renforcement de l'offre
sociale l'opposition est s'est une fois
encore de se poser en défenseur des
classes moyennes sans en définir le
champ ni donné de propositions est un
peu apparemment familière du concept de
progressivité de l'impôt elle passe sous
silence le fait que la mesure annoncée
ne produira ses effets qu'au delà de
5000 euros de revenus mensuels pour un
couple avec deux enfants et ne produira
ses effets maximum aux alentours 9000
euros de revenus or comme le soulignait
martin hirsch mardi dernier dans le
journal le monde ce sont dans ces
tranches de revenus représentant 12% des
ménages que le bénéfice des prestations
familiales est le plus élevé
c'est la conséquence de leurs versements
sans condition de ressources l'héritage
sur lequel le gouvernement jugeait avec
raison qu'il ne fallait pas revenir
réagir en assurant un financement
renforcée
ce n'est pas attaqué certaines familles
c'est garantir à l'ensemble d'entre
elles un financement pérenne des
mécanismes de soutien vous le faites
avec le souci de la justice
his en augmentant par ailleurs les aides
aux familles les plus modestes soutenir
les familles s'est développée par
exemple l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes en partageant entre eux le
congé parental d'éducation
les sénateurs socialistes à ceci les
sénateurs sa série s'associe à cette
démarche et nous ne sommes pas les seuls
vous avez pu le constater lors du débat
consacré à la politique familiale le 16
mai dernier sur ses bancs
le groupe crc par exemple il soutenait
également la modulation du quotient
familial plutôt que la réduction au labo
nul à sion des prestations l'impôt sur
le revenu et le levier naturel de la
redistribution en procurant un milliard
d'euros de ressources nouvelles
la réduction du quotient engage le
redressement votre question chocolat il
sait le faire
donc madame la ministre pouvez-vous nous
exposer le détail des mesures que ses
ressources nouvelles permettront de
peindre merci la parole à madame
dominique bertinotti ministre chargée de
la famille monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur effectivement c'est
un effort sans précédent mené avec
beaucoup de détermination qui va être
pris en particulier dans le
développement des modes d'accueil des 0
3 ans je voudrais rappeler que
l'évolution du fonds national d'action
sociale de la cnaf
lors de la précédente convention
d'objectifs et de gestion que vous avez
signé passer de 4 à 4,6 milliards
lorsque nous nous allons le faire passer
de 4 6 milliards à 6,6 milliards
vous connaissez mal les ressorts de la
branche famille je suis déçu et le le
fna ce effectivement cette augmentation
substantielle de duffy das va permettre
la création de 275 mille places
d'accueil des 0-3 ans qui se ventile
rond de la façon suivante cent mille
places en crèche lorsque vous n'en avez
créé que soixante mille cent mille
c'est auprès des assistantes maternelles
lorsque vous n'en avez créé que 80
milles et enfin 75 mille places de
préscolarisation lorsque vous vous en
avez supprimé 55000 le deuxième axe de
la politique volontariste de ce
gouvernement c'est aussi de développer
le soutien à la parentalité temps il est
urgent d'en finir avec la politique de
stigmatisation des familles qui a été la
vôtre et qui se traduira en termes
budgétaires par le doublement du budget
du soutien à la parentalité qui passera
de 50 millions à 100 millions
les efforts sont des efforts
substantiels
tout simplement tout simplement parce
qu'aujourd'hui nos concitoyens ne
demande pas simplement que des
prestations financières mais aussi des
services et je ne comprends pas que vous
ne puissiez pas vous engager avec autant
de détermination vers cette voie là car
assurer le développement économique de
vos territoires investir et faire en
sorte que les entreprises soient
intéressés par vos territoires c'est la
capacité à offrir une qualité de service
aux futurs salariés dans cette qualité
des futurs services aux salariés
le fait de pouvoir concilier vie
professionnelle et vie personnelle et
donc d'offrir des places en crèche est
un élément fondamental les électeurs en
2014 seront appréciées
merci la parole et à monsieur bruno sido
pour le groupe ump
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur et intéresse probablement
beaucoup de mes collègues sur ses bancs
et ils attendent une réponse précise
monsieur le ministre la décision du
conseil constitutionnel du 16 mai 2013
censure pour partie l'article 46 de la
loi relative à l'élection des
conseillers départementaux et municipaux
et intercommunaux elle contrarie le
dialogue que vous avez instauré entre
les préfet les élus sur les modification
des limites territoriales des cantons en
limitant à la seule notion d'intérêt
général
les cas de dérogation qui permettent aux
futurs territoire d'élection de pouvoir
compter un nombre d'habitants qui
diffère d'une moyenne départementale le
conseil constitutionnel modifie les
termes des consultations engagées sur le
terrain
en effet comme vous l'avez souhaité les
préfets ont consulté les élus sur ces
questions et vous ont adressé pour
chaque département une synthèse de
préconisations issues des territoires je
ne doute pas que les services de du
bureau des élections ou un autre bureau
n 2 du ministère d'intérieur seront à
tirer la substantifique moelle
seulement à cette époque nous avions à
l'esprit la création d'un tunnel
autorisant des variation de plus ou
moins 20 ou 30% autour d'une moyenne
départementale d'habitants afin de
soutenir la ruralité
l'assemblée nationale a refusé cette
approche de bon sens lui préférant une
énumération à la prévert de cas de
dérogation énumération d'ailleurs j'ai
trop générale par le conseil
constitutionnel est censuré pour le
risque de délimitation arbitraire
encourus aujourd'hui afin que le
dialogue se poursuive dans le cadre
d'une réflexion stabiliser je vous
remercie infiniment monsieur le ministre
de bien vouloir indiquer au sénat
si les opérations de remodelage des
circonscriptions électorales se base ou
s'appuie sur la nouvelle carte
intercommunale
si d'une manière ou d'une autre des
variations de population de plus ou
moins d'un pour cent seront remises
entre
permise entre les différents cantons et
si oui par quels mécanismes juridiques
il s'agit bien là de soutenir de
défendre la ruralité
troisièmement à quel moment mesdames et
messieurs les préfets recevront du
ministère un projet de nouvelle carte
cantonale et enfin si la méthode et les
mêmes critères seront appliqués dans
tous les départements dans le même état
d'esprit
nonobstant les spécificités montagnarde
ou ultramarines de certains d'entre eux
je vous remercie
merci monsieur manuel valls ministre de
l'intérieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur bruno sido d'abord soyez beau
joueur
le gouvernement se félicite de la
décision rendue le 16 mai dernier par le
conseil constitutionnel qui a confirmé
la constitutionnalité du mode de scrutin
binominal majoritaire c'est une victoire
pour la démocratie
c'est une victoire pour l'equilibre dans
le département et c'est une victoire
d'abord et avant tout pour la parité et
je vous rappelle enfin se veut que ce
que vous comptez astier également qu' il
a accepté il a autorisé également le
renvoi des élections régionales et
départementales en 2015 cette décision
entérine les grands principes du
redécoupage cantonal la primauté du
principe d'égalité du suffrage est donc
une limitation stricte les écarts la
moyenne et celle règle s'applique et
c'est normal vous avez rappelé que le
conseil constitutionnel a censuré des
dispositions
considérant qu'elle ne pouvait être
inscrite dans la loi parce qu'elle
n'avait pas été de portée générale pour
autant la décision du conseil précise
elle même ces exceptions géographique
qui sont proches de celles qui avaient
été votées
l'insularité le relief l'enclavement la
superficie et ces ajustements sont
conformes monsieur le sénateur à
l'esprit des propositions du
gouvernement et aux engagements pris au
cours des débats au parlement et ne
regrettez pas la décision du conseil
constitutionnel
en tout cas il faut en tirer les
conséquences c'est vous qui avait saisi
le conseil constitutionnel le conseil
constitutionnel a donné raison sur
l'essentiel de la loi a censuré un point
qui reste dans l'esprit
de la loi mais vous n'avez qu'à vous en
prendre vous et à l'ump pour cette
censure pour avoir choisi le conseil
constitutionnel il faut être cohérent
monsieur le sénateur canton n'alerte le
gouvernement enfin je vous rappelle et
c'est là l'essentiel
un peu de malice quand même nous avons
eu lieu ce débat les concertations les
consultations commencent les préfets
sont saisis les présidents de conseils
généraux et les élus également ce
travail va durer sauf pendant la période
estivale comme nous étions engagés
le conseil d'état va être après les avis
des départements est régulièrement
puisqu'il s'agira pas de présenter un
bloc le conseil d'état examinera les
découpages par département il faudra que
ce travail de concertation qui doit
tenir compte de l' équilibre des
territoires et qui les politiques de la
concertation cela doit se faire
contrairement à ce qui s'est passé sur
un certain nombre de découpage
il y a quelques années et croyez moi moi
j'en suis convaincu les départements
sortiront renforcés grâce à ce nouveau
découpage et grâce à la parité
nous aurons ainsi tous contribué à
approfondir la démocratie dans notre
pays
merci mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues nous en
avons fini avec des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 16h15 pour la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi de
modernisation de l'action publique
territoriale et d'affirmation des
métropoles
la séance est suspendue
voilà vous avez pu suivre en direct les
questions d'actualité au sénat nous on
refait la séance en quelques secondes
alors on refait la séance on refait donc
les questions d'actualité au sénat des
questions d'actualité qui ont été
marquée par un hommage solennel dans
l'hémicycle après l'agression mortelle
de clément mairie que c'était